Understanding our own racial biases is something we all struggle with, even when we aren't aware of those struggles. We speak with one psychologist who has been studying a more modern form of prejudice and says ridding ourselves of those biases is practically impossible. But being aware of them is the first step toward improving relations among different racial groups. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. John DeVito is a psychology professor at Yale University and one of the leading researchers on racism, particularly subtle or unconscious racism. He has studied issues of social power and social relations, both between groups and between individuals. His work explores techniques for reducing these conscious and unconscious biases. Welcome, Dr. DeVideo.
理解我们自身的种族偏见是我们每个人都在努力克服的事情，即使我们并没有意识到这些挣扎。我们采访了一位心理学家，他一直在研究一种更现代的偏见形式，并表示要消除这些偏见几乎是不可能的。但意识到它们是改善不同种族群体之间关系的第一步。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。约翰·德维托是耶鲁大学的心理学教授，也是种族主义，特别是微妙或无意识种族主义领域的主要研究人员之一。他研究了群体之间和个人之间的社会权力和社会关系问题。他的工作探索了减少这些有意识和无意识偏见的技术。欢迎您，德维托博士。
Thank you for having me. Your work focuses on what you call aversive racism. Can you explain what that means and how it differs from just one? racism? We used to think about racism in a very simple way, that people had negative thoughts, negative feelings, hatred towards a group. But since the 1960s, whether it was the civil rights legislation, it changed the way we thought about race because it was not only immoral to think that way, but it was illegal to discriminate.
谢谢你邀请我。你的工作重点是你所说的“厌恶型种族主义”。你能解释一下这意味着什么，以及它与普通的种族主义有何不同吗？我们过去以一种非常简单的方式看待种族主义，认为人们对某个群体有负面想法、负面情绪和仇恨。但自20世纪60年代以来，无论是民权立法，还是其他因素，都改变了我们对种族的看法，因为那样思考不仅是不道德的，而且歧视也是违法的。
And what we think is that racism has become more subtle since then, that people still have negative feelings, but they may not be aware of those negative feelings. and instead of feelings of hatred, it's more like feelings of avoidance and discomfort. That's where the name of verse of racism comes from. Would you say most people have some biases against people from different racial or ethnic groups? You know, what are the consequences of those types of implicit, or we say unconscious biases? Yeah. There's research that shows that only a small proportion of Americans today have old-fashioned kind of racism,
我们认为，从那时起，种族主义变得更加微妙了，人们仍然有负面情绪，但他们可能没有意识到这些负面情绪。与其说是仇恨，不如说是回避和不适感。这就是“厌恶型种族主义”这个名字的由来。你会说大多数人对来自不同种族或族裔群体的人都有一些偏见吗？你知道，这些类型的内隐偏见，或者我们所说的无意识偏见，会带来什么后果吗？是的。有研究表明，今天只有一小部分美国人持有老式的种族主义，
explicit kind of racism, but the majority of white Americans, because they've grown up in a culture that has been historically racist in many ways, because they're exposed to the media that associates violence, drugs, and poverty with certain groups, most white Americans, the majority of white Americans, about two-thirds to three-quarters, have these unconscious, implicit racial biases. How do people work on getting rid of these biases if they don't know they're biased? That's the biggest challenge because most of us are really well practiced at convincing ourselves that we're not prejudiced. So most of us want to be good people. Prejudice is bad.
即显性的种族主义，但大多数白人美国人，因为他们成长在一个在许多方面历史上都存在种族主义的文化中，因为他们接触的媒体将暴力、毒品和贫困与特定群体联系在一起，大多数白人美国人，大约三分之二到四分之三，都有这种无意识的、内隐的种族偏见。如果人们不知道自己有偏见，他们该如何努力消除这些偏见呢？这是最大的挑战，因为我们大多数人都非常擅长说服自己我们没有偏见。所以我们大多数人都想成为好人。偏见是不好的。
And when we think about it, we always do the right thing. One of the consequences of aversive racism or unconscious bias is that you don't discriminate in a situation where what's right and wrong is clearly defined. Because you know what you're supposed to do when you do it. But it usually happens when you can justify a response on the basis of some factor other than race. So there may be like two people that you're interviewing, one white and one black, and you shift your criteria for the job in a way that actually favors the white person without actually directly discriminating against it. So the problem is every time we look at our behavior and monitor our behavior,
当我们思考这个问题时，我们总是认为自己在做正确的事。厌恶型种族主义或无意识偏见的一个后果是，在是非界限明确的情况下，你不会表现出歧视。因为你知道在那种情况下你应该做什么。但它通常发生在你能够以种族以外的某种因素为由为自己的反应辩护时。所以，比如你正在面试两个人，一个是白人，一个是黑人，你改变了工作标准，以一种实际上偏袒白人的方式，而没有直接歧视黑人。所以问题在于，每次我们审视自己的行为并监控自己的行为时，
we behave in egalitarian way. and it's only when we're not paying attention that we discriminate. And so to your question, what we have to do is probably, if something's unconscious, you don't know you have it. It's that simple. So you can't think about what you're really feeling, but what you have to do is assume that you probably have these biases if you're an average American.
我们表现得都很平等。只有当我们不注意时，我们才会表现出歧视。所以回到你的问题，我们必须做的是，如果某种偏见是无意识的，你根本不知道自己有它。就是这么简单。所以你无法思考你真正的感受，但你必须假设如果你是一个普通的美国人，你可能就有这些偏见。
And then what you have to do is try to control those biases in the way you behave towards people. you often have to acknowledge that you may have these biases. So it's an ongoing battle because you can't really get rid of these. They're like habits of mind that we've grown up with. And so you just have to work at being always alert, always conscious, and always receptive to the possibility that we might be biased. I hear a lot about when you're eliminating these biases.
然后你必须做的是尝试在你对待他人的方式中控制这些偏见。你通常必须承认你可能存在这些偏见。所以这是一场持续的战斗，因为你无法真正消除它们。它们就像我们从小养成的思维习惯。因此，你必须努力保持时刻警惕、时刻清醒，并时刻接受我们可能存在偏见的可能性。我经常听到关于消除这些偏见的事情。
A lot of it is just about having conversations about race in general, maybe with people who are not your racial or ethnic background. Do you think that that helps sort of uncover these biases that you don't know you have? Yeah. One of the problem with averse of racism that I mentioned before is that you actually avoid the group. Okay. And you avoid the group because they make you uncomfortable, and you can therefore maintain your stereotypes of the group.
其中很大一部分只是关于进行关于种族的对话，也许是与那些不是你种族或族裔背景的人进行对话。你认为这有助于揭示那些你不知道自己拥有的偏见吗？是的。我之前提到的厌恶型种族主义的问题之一是，你实际上是在回避这个群体。好的。你回避这个群体是因为他们让你感到不舒服，因此你可以维持你对该群体的刻板印象。
If you have a lot of interaction with members of the group, then you no longer think about it. about people as being a member of that group primarily. You think about them as individuals. And so you haven't really gotten rid of the implicit bias, but you've been able to fine-tune the way you interact with many different people. And you just develop a broader array of repertoire
如果你与该群体的成员有很多互动，那么你就不再把他们仅仅视为该群体的成员。你会把他们视为个体。所以你并没有真正消除内隐偏见，但你已经能够微调你与许多不同人互动的方式。你只是发展出了更广泛的互动能力，
of being able to interact with people and understand them. What do psychologists like you who study this, think about the election and reelection of President Obama, have race relations and attitudes changed in this country since he became president? There's been some amazing changes in terms of attitudes since he's become president, but there's also been a real persistence of racism. In terms of changing of attitudes, it probably has happened among the black community because
能够与人互动并理解他们。像你这样研究这个问题的心理学家如何看待奥巴马总统的当选和连任？自他担任总统以来，这个国家的种族关系和态度发生了变化吗？自他担任总统以来，在态度方面发生了一些惊人的变化，但种族主义也确实存在。在改变态度方面，这可能发生在黑人社区中，因为
there are new role models. Blacks can envision a new future. Blacks can be at the center rather than the periphery. But many of the issues that you saw with Obama in terms of objections to him, the questions about where he was born is a reflection of averse of racism where a black person in that position of power can't be legitimate in that position of power. And so you look for reasons to try to devalue or get rid of that person. The other thing is that many of his policies have been opposed in ways that are much more
出现了新的榜样。黑人可以设想一个新的未来。黑人可以处于中心位置，而不是边缘。但你在奥巴马身上看到的许多问题，就反对他的意见而言，关于他出生地的质疑，反映了厌恶型种族主义，即一个处于权力地位的黑人不能在那个权力位置上具有合法性。所以你会寻找理由试图贬低或除掉那个人。另一件事是，他的许多政策遭到了反对，其方式比许多其他总统更
virulent than many other presidents. I think it's a part because those negative racial attitudes get expressed, get channeled in a way that has a higher intensity. Have psychologists been studying this? I mean, in the last, I guess it's sort of an ongoing experiment of the last eight years of his presidency. Over the last eight years, there have been some changes in implicit racial bias, but not widespread. So a study, too, will find a difference, particularly soon after the election. election because it was so revolutionary at the time in terms of thinking.
恶毒。我认为这部分是因为那些负面的种族态度得到了表达，并以一种强度更高的方式被引导出来。心理学家一直在研究这个问题吗？我的意思是，在过去的八年里，这算是一个持续的实验。在过去的八年里，内隐种族偏见发生了一些变化，但并不普遍。所以，一两项研究会发现差异，特别是在选举后不久。选举，因为在当时看来，这在思想上是如此具有革命性。
And we had just stopped thinking to revolutionary things. But when you go back to business as usual, we still grow up in a society that makes these associations. And he's seen really as an exception rather than what the average black person is. Let's move on to the topic of law enforcement. What can law enforcement officers and their leaders learn from your research when it comes to training and interacting with their communities, specifically minority communities. The research on police offices, well, in general, they started doing some research with
我们刚刚停止思考革命性的事情。但当你回到一切照旧的状态时，我们仍然成长在一个会产生这些联想的社会中。他被视为一个例外，而不是普通黑人的样子。让我们转向执法的话题。当涉及到培训和与社区，特别是少数族裔社区互动时，执法人员及其领导者能从你的研究中学到什么？关于警察的研究，嗯，总的来说，他们开始做一些研究，使用
different computer simulation games where you would shoot and not shoot somebody that appeared on a screen and that person either had a gun or had an object like a wallet. And then you would have to make a decision do you shoot or not shoot that person. And what that research found was two things. One was that people were much more likely to shoot an unarmed black person than an unarmed white person. And second of all, implicit bias predicted that result. There's this, on average, this kind of shooter bias.
不同的计算机模拟游戏，你会在屏幕上射击或不射击某人，那个人要么拿着枪，要么拿着像钱包一样的物体。然后你必须做出决定，你是射击还是不射击那个人。这项研究发现了两件事。第一，人们射击手无寸铁的黑人比射击手无寸铁的白人的可能性要大得多。第二，内隐偏见预测了这一结果。平均而言，存在这种“射手偏见”。
And this shooter bias is related to implicit attitudes. And work with police officers show that they show the same bias. that it is related to their implicit attitudes as well. The more they are exposed in their daily activity to black violence, the police officers, the more likely they are to show this kind of bias. So what it talks about is that nobody wants to shoot an unarmed person. That's not our intentions. But what it shows is if you have these very quick associations of blacks with crime and violence,
这种射手偏见与内隐态度有关。对警察的研究表明，他们也表现出同样的偏见，这也与他们的内隐态度有关。警察在日常活动中接触黑人暴力越多，他们就越有可能表现出这种偏见。所以这说明的是，没有人想射击手无寸铁的人。那不是我们的意图。但它表明，如果你有这种将黑人与犯罪和暴力联系起来的非常快速的联想，
if you're well trained in your profession, it makes you susceptible to making a split-second decision that you can never take back. How do they go about eliminating those biases, or is that even possible? Yeah, I'm not a big fan of trying to eliminate the biases. You know, biases that are 50 years in the making, you don't unmake in a very short time. Okay. But one example, I do some work with police forces indirectly through. an organization I'm part of, but one of the things that they said was that police officers
如果你在你的职业中训练有素，这会使你容易做出一个你永远无法收回的瞬间决定。他们如何去消除这些偏见，或者这甚至可能吗？是的，我不太热衷于试图消除这些偏见。你知道，50年形成的偏见，你不可能在很短的时间内消除。好的。但举个例子，我通过我所属的一个组织间接地与警察部队合作，但他们说的一件事是，警察
today aren't like the image we had of police officers in the past walking the beat. The police officers today are in a car that has so much electronics that they don't have to get out of their car. Someone even told me, I don't know if this is actually true, but I bet it is, that there's more electronics, high power electronics in the average police car today than there was in our first space shots. So what that means is the police officers are in the car and don't interact with the community. And the community sees the police officers as distant and powerful over them.
今天不像我们过去印象中那样在街上巡逻。今天的警察坐在车里，车里有太多的电子设备，他们甚至不需要下车。甚至有人告诉我，我不知道这是否属实，但我敢打赌是真的，今天普通警车里的电子设备比我们第一次太空发射时的还要多。所以这意味着警察坐在车里，不与社区互动。社区认为警察是疏远的，并且对他们拥有权力。
And you can't be an effective police officer unless you have the trust and cooperation of the community. So what they've tried to do now, and we've recommended this in several places, was to basically get the police officer out of the car, just as you said before, to meet the people. as individuals to be able to distinguish one from the other and therefore not overreact. Okay, Dr. DeVito, thank you so much for joining us. It's been such a pleasure. It's been a pleasure for me too. Thank you. For more information on Dr. DeVito's work and to hear more episodes,
除非你拥有社区的信任和合作，否则你不可能成为一名有效的警察。所以他们现在尝试做的事情，我们在几个地方也推荐过，基本上就是让警察走出车外，就像你刚才说的那样，去见见人们。作为个体去区分彼此，从而不会反应过度。好的，德维托博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这真是太愉快了。对我来说也很愉快。谢谢。有关德维托博士工作的更多信息并收听更多剧集，
please go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。